it is time now for CBS deals and this
morning we have just a few things that
might make the perfect Father's Day gift
or might be something for you for
yourself we love that and all that
exclusive discounts to start shopping
just scan that QR code on your screen or
visit
cbsdeals.com our girl Ashley Bellman our
lifestyle expert she joins us now with
more what you got for it okay so many
cool things today and and the deals are
so good one for Dad one for you maybe
one for your mom because hey why not
okay first up we have clock at golf this
is so great a woman invented this
because she wanted to hit golf balls
practice her game in her own yard do you
remember last week when you tried to hit
the ball in the studio no I did that
very nervous
this is like tetherball for golf okay so
you can put this in your backyard you
don't have to go to the driving range
you don't have to go to the golf club
easy it comes assembled you just screw
it into the ground practice your swing
my Dad's getting one but also I'm gonna
get one for my Dad's neighbor who's
always is hitting the balls into his
yard so it's just it's just good all
around 30 off today 41.99 I can't
believe this hasn't been thought of yet
I know you know Jeffrey Todd is eyeing
this ball here I am really dying to demo
but let her do it I was honestly
surprised I have a little area set up I
absolutely love tetherball so I get it
okay I get it now if you want to play
golf in the dark in your backyard and
have some music playing Rush charge has
you covered this is a flashlight that is
like the Swiss army knife of flashlights
it's eight in one so we have the front
flashing light fog light emergency light
and then it also on the side we have an
emergency light and um we were talking
about the mosquitoes a mosquito light so
you put this outside on your back table
and it's going to stop the mosquitoes
from coming which is I'm always looking
for that because I am the one who gets
bit so also Bluetooth speaker and you
can charge your phone with this they
also have a great deal on this portable
charger this is a power station and this
does not need to be plugged in anywhere
if you know someone who has an RV
someone that goes camping a lot it's
going to charge everything from your
phone to a refrigerator for up to two
days you could use it use it as a
generator you you do Char you do charge
it though you charge it and then then it
goes out by exactly so the deals are
great on this 59.99 the savings started
today that's for the flashlight up to 53
off I know this is great it's one of
those things that everybody should have
either in the garage or if you are the
camper have a boat whatever it is you're
doing this summer you need this I could
have used this my car died the ultimate
death and I'm I'm betting it could have
I'm telling you one of each for the car
in the house there it is okay so this my
husband snatched this the second it
arrived at my house it's like a black
wolf sonic scrubber no more loofahs in
no no because they're they have lots of
unhygienic things that we won't talk
about but this is awesome okay so you
turn it on it vibrates it pulsates it's
charcoal infused soft silicone and it's
anti bacterial bristles really yes
waterproof chart is going to stay nice
and there's a couple different pulsing
different it's like it's going to make
the shower a spa experience you could
use it on your body use it on your back
the the handle will extend so you can
get those hard to reach places and you
can use your face as well 44 19 yeah
Face Body and this is going to come with
the body scrub also 35 office that's a
keeper yes what's going on okay so this
is so cool so this is working steps this
is going to make any collar perfect so
you know in the collars even if you get
them pressed you put this in here you
magnetize it look so easy look at that
put it on and then your collar isn't so
perfect how much this is such a great
deal this is starting at 9.95 there's
lots of bundles up to 50 off here wow I
know a couple of men who want to see
this thank you so much Ashley of course
we will partner with all of these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything you saw today and that QR code
on your Spooner head on over to
cbsdeals.com